okay so we've got to talk today about
some tweets that have surfaced from
congresswoman Ilan Omar and Rasheeda
Talib where they appeared to also be
calling for the deportation of American
citizens something that Donald Trump has
been heavily and correctly criticized
for over the last 10 days so let me set
this back up for you from the beginning
Donald Trump tweeted back on July 14th
it's been 10 days now since this started
quote so interesting to see progressive
Democrat Congress women who originally
came from countries whose governments
are a complete and total catastrophe the
worst most corrupt and inept anywhere in
the world if they even have a
functioning government at all
now loudly and viciously telling the
people of the United States the greatest
and most powerful nation on earth how
our government is to be run why don't
they go back and help fix the totally
broken and crime-infested places from
which they came then come back and show
us how it is done these places need your
help badly you can't leave fast enough
I'm sure that Nancy Pelosi would be very
happy to quickly work out free travel
arrangements and this was followed by a
chant at a Donald Trump rally in North
Carolina about a week ago or so where at
the mere mention of Alon Omar by Donald
Trump the crowd started chanting send
her back send her back
and she talked about the evil Israel so
this is undeniably xenophobic it's
disgusting its anti-american the
president of the United States
suggesting that not not only legal
American citizens but also just legally
elected officials who are members of the
House of Representatives be sent back or
leave and go back to their quote
original countries it's absolutely and
totally disgusting it's also counter to
the idea that Donald Trump has espoused
for years that if you don't like what's
going on in the United States then you
should work to change it I mean all of
Obama's presidency Donald Trump's
perspective was I don't like what's
happening in the country as a result of
Barack Obama I want it to change
and eventually I want it to change by
running for president if members of
Congress want to change the country for
the better as they see it Trump says
they should leave and go back to their
quote original countries Donald Trump's
entire campaign was based on not leaving
and going somewhere else
maybe Germany where Trump's family came
from but I'm trying to improve the
country that you live in
so anyway total hypocrisy now we get to
this latest revelation which is that it
starts to get a little complicated
because at least two members of the
so-called squad these four ethnic
minority
congresswoman congresswoman Rasheeda
Talib and congresswoman Ilan Omar are on
record as appearing to suggest the
deportation of people that they don't
like now I received probably fifty or
sixty emails in the last twelve hours
some from the right saying David you are
a shill for the left and you will not
cover that alone Omar and Rashida Talib
have also tweeted about deporting people
that are legally here in the United
States I received roughly half of those
fifty or sixty emails were from people
on the Left who said David you don't
need to cover this because it's a
non-story and the tweets by Alon Omar
and Rasheeda Talib are completely
different than what Donald Trump has
said and done well I'm going to cover it
likely to the displeasure of everybody
who listens or watches because it does
deserve cover
but it is also true that these comments
from the congresswoman the now Congress
women which is an important thing to
mention are not the same as what Donald
Trump said so let's look first at Ilan
Omar back in October of 2012 a twitter
user posted an article about a Maine
mayor a mayor in the state of Maine
saying that Somalis should leave their
culture at the door in the United States
a twitter battle developed Ilan Omar
took the position that Somalis don't
need to leave their culture at the door
that America is a melting pot and then
eventually Olano mart weeded quote we
are citizens and can't be deported
why don't we deport you to wherever you
came from now I have to tell you this
does not seem to me to be Alana Maher
suggesting that citizens be deported I
see this as Alana Mar saying that
deporting her as a Somali born but now
American citizen is no more logical than
than deporting any of the US citizens
that are arguing with Alana Maher on
Twitter about how Somalis should leave
their culture at the door I don't see
this as the same as go back to your
country your original country or
whatever I see this more as it's absurd
to be telling anyone me or you to go
back to your country now this is not a
defense of Ilan Omar reflexively as many
of you know and have criticized me for I
don't agree with many of Elana Mars sort
of approaches to politics and even some
of her political positions she's very
much for the BDS movement to boycott
Israel I'm against that movement I've
explained why it's not the topic of
today's program I have no incentive to
reflexively defend Ilan Omar if she
doesn't deserve defending I just don't
think this is the same as what Donald
Trump said and more importantly she was
not President of the United States when
she tweeted that nor was she even a
member of Congress so I believe I forget
the date now on that tweet then we get
to Rasheeda Talib who back in December
of 2015
tweeted about Donald Trump deport this
a-hole now this one is not so easily
defensible this is pretty direct and
clear the
only real difference is that Rasheeda
Talib in 2015 was a member of the
Michigan House of Representatives not a
member of Congress and not a President
of the United States now I still
disagree with what she said as I
disagree with what Donald Trump said but
if Republicans are going to take the
position that when Trump said it it was
merely symbolic and meant to say they
disagree that he disagrees with the
policies of the squad if they are going
to take the position that when Trump's
followers chanted sent her back it was
merely symbolic a way to say we disagree
with the politics of Olano Maher then I
don't know how you can't also sort of be
forced logically into accepting that
when rashida to leave is saying deport
this a-hole it is the same type of
symbolism that is I disagree with this
person's politics and I don't think he's
good for the country I don't like this
stuff I don't like any of it but the
truth is that what alon omar said is not
the same as what Donald Trump said what
Rasheeda Talib said is actually closer
to what Donald Trump said but again if
we are saying that these are symbolic
political statements we have to apply
that to receipt it to leave statement as
well otherwise we are hypocrites which I
know doesn't matter to the right anymore
but it matters to me
so I talked about it I don't know how
many people will agree with my
perspective here that these are comments
worthy of commentary but there is a
distinction between them and what Donald
Trump has been saying I want to hear
from you make sure if you're watching
this clip on YouTube that you are
subscribed to our channel hit the
subscribe button we are now beyond seven
hundred and two thousand subscribers if
you are listening on the radio or
watching on TV or whatever you can
either find this clip on youtube and
comment on it or tweet me at de Pakman